tiens renouil vous êtes notre envoyé
spécial dans la capitale ukrainienne
qu'elles sont tout simplement les
dernières informations dont vous
disposez sur la situation à mario paul
bonjour très peu d'informations en
réalité puisque l'onu et le comité
international de la croix rouge qui
organise cette évacuation ne communique
pas pour l'instant alors le peu
d'informations dont je dispose me
proviennent du gouvernement ukrainien il
ya en réalité deux évacuations qui
doivent avoir lieu aujourd'hui à
marioupol la première dans l'usinage
ostal ou sont encore retranchés des
centaines de civils sous les décombres
de cette usine qui est attaqué depuis
près de deux mois par l'armée russe et
les autres depuis le centre-ville de
marioupol qui est occupé en ce moment
par les russes nous il ya beaucoup moins
deux combats alors quand ces civils
vont-ils pouvoir être évacués vont-ils
même pouvoir être évacués c'est très
compliqué à dire puisque des convois
similaires devaient avoir lieu lors des
derniers jours et seul l'un d'entre eux
la semaine dernière a pu rejoindre la
ville de zappos ridja où attendent des
médecins des psychologues qui vont
prendre en charge tous ces civils qui
sont restés bloqués durant près de deux
mois au sein de l'usiné et qui sont tous
très touchés physiquement et tous très
traumatisés après avoir vécu nombre de
bombardements et d'attac de l'armée
russe donc vont-ils réussir de nouveau
aujourd'hui à parvenir à aller voir ces
civils impossible de le dire pour
l'heure toujours est-il qu'il sera
extrêmement compliqué de les évacuer de
la zone puisqu'il ya plusieurs
checkpoints à la sortie de l'usiné azote
stahl des checkpoints qui sont tenus par
l'armée russe l'armée qui vérifie les
passeports les cartes d'identité des
personnes qui étaient dans l'usiné afin
de s'assurer bien qu'il n'y a que des
civils des femmes des enfants des
personnes âgées et non pas des
combattants des combattants blessés
notamment qui sont extrêmement nombreux
à l'intérieur de cette usine et qui
demande d'ailleurs à être évacués c'est
une demande qu'on voit régulièrement
depuis plusieurs semaines de la part des
militaires l'ukrainien qui sont bloqués
dans cette usine il demande de l'aide
internationale pour pouvoir quitter
cette zone pour pouvoir rejoindre
rejoindre une zone plus sûre il ne
serait pas sous les bombardements de
l'armée russe mais voilà l'armée russe
s'y opposent elle continue à attaquer le
site malgré les annonces de cessez le
feu il y a toujours régulièrement des
bombardements est d'ailleurs bien
l'armée russe est toujours présente dans
mario paul même si elle s'éloigne un
petit peu du centre ville pourquoi parce
qu il semblerait selon le gouvernement
ukrainien que des aménagements soient
faits dans mario paul que la ville soit
nettoyé qu'ils enlèvent les décombres
qu'ils enlèvent les cadavres des rues
pour pouvoir le 9 mai prochain célébrer
cette grande journée très importante
pour la russie la journée de la victoire
2 le rsa sur l'allemagne nazie une fête
importante pour vladimir poutine qui a
besoin de montrer une victoire et qui
donc contre apparemment semble-t-il
selon le gouvernement ukrainien l'a
célébré dans mario paul merci beaucoup
bastien pour toutes ces précisions vous
retrouve bien sûr tout au long de cette
journée